was 33 years old working in my dad's  liquor store owning nothing of the  business and had to start over at 34  because I built a family business for my  parents I had the patience to say it's  okay I'm 33 30 I'm going to be 34. I'm  going to do this for 50 more years I  have kids rolling up at me at 26 27  thinking their careers are over and I  have 40 year olds and 50 year olds who  actually think they're done with life  and I'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing  you're going to live another 50 years  like when we think about Vera Wang the  colonel who did Kentucky Fried Chicken  or city Frank who did Gray Goose these  are real there are people who from zero  or from a small base in their 50s 60s  70s and 80s have built meaningful things  I just wish people realized how  important patience was in Alpha business  building I am as ambitious as they come  my great Fortune is my ambition is  matched with my patience